dear Heavenly Father we ask you today
for the opportunity to be here and for
each person that fills this room we ask
you to guide us in our efforts to make
the best decisions on behalf of the
district give us a desire to find ways
to excel in our work and encourage
others to be kind to each other and
bring out the best of all all of us
gathered here today we all have ideas
vision talent and ability and we ask you
to guide our hearts and minds in the
spirit of fairness equality and speech
so that we may reach a successful and
clear conclusion to the issues that are
in front of us today we ask this in the
name Lord Jesus Christ amen welcome to
this October meeting of the council my
first of all remind you of some domestic
arrangements toilets are situated
outside the meeting room opposite the
stairs cold water is also available in
the breakout area outside the meeting
room if the fire alarm should sound
please leave the meeting room by the
following the fire exit signs and meet
on the Ipswich Town Football Club
training pitch do not re-enter the
building until you're told it's safe to
do so please switch off all mobile
phones or turn them to silent I would
like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the Internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except when there
are confidential or exempt items if you
make a representation to the meeting
you'll be deemed by the council to have
consented to being filmed by entering
this room you are also consenting to
being filmed by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and all
training purposes the council
members of the public and the press may
recalled film photograph or broadcast
this meeting when the public and the
press are not lawfully excluded finally
can members and officers please ensure
that you press the microphone for
speaking and turn off when you have
finished now before I move on to take
gender please can I remind members so an
extraordinary meeting is being held
immediately after this one which I'll
need to formally open and then withdraw
the item on the agenda therefore I ask
all members to remain in their seats
after this meeting closes I'll now move
to the agenda please pop one apologies
for absence thank you chair I have not
received anything declaration of
interest by councillors
thank you no declarations 0.3 BC 1921 to
confirm the minutes of the meeting held
on 24 September 2019 for accuracy only
are there any issues with that pura see
Thank You chairman on page 12 item eight
point five it says the cabinet member
for economic growth responded he wasn't
present I responded on his behalf
Thank You council Aarthi did you have a
comment thank you yes
page 14 8 10 third paragraph 811
attendances should read 881 Thank You
cats merci
so any further comments or matters of
accuracy cancer Hinton thank you madam
chairman as the leader of the councils
brought it up paragraph page 12
paragraph 8.5 it does state that the
cabinet member who wasn't there
or the leader acting on his behalf
responded the nafs' will be circulated
after the meeting how long after the
meeting a week to expect that response
because I haven't seen anything yet
[Applause]
so that would be check chased up thank
you hopefully that will be coming soon
can we now vote for the amended minutes
please can I have a proposer please
capsule Osbourne can I have a seconder
please councillor Ward thank you all
those in favor that's carried thank you
item 4 BC 1922 announcements from the
Kerman and leader I refer you to paper
BC 1922 for noting Thank You councillor
Ward have you anything to report I was
not intending to give him that I didn't
have time as a result of personal
circumstances last week however I
attended this morning the finance
briefing on business rates and there
weren't many people there it is been
rerun against tomorrow at 4:30 and I do
highly recommend this it's a very
important and very complicated topic and
members do need to get their heads
around as much as they can so and it's
Authority good presentation by Melissa
and Katherine and I think as many people
that please as possible get along to it
it's it's well worth it
Thank You counsel award we'll move on
now to item 5 to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with council
procedure rules Thank You chair none
have been received item 6 questions by
the public in accordance with council
procedure rules questions received in
accordance with council council
procedure rule 12 mr. lambing would you
like to come forward and ask your
questions thank you madam chairman I
have two questions the first is to ask
the leader of the council the undated
report BC stroke 19 stroke 20 from the
leader renaming Baber District Council
for consideration at an extraordinary
meeting of the council convened for 6:30
p.m. today States at paragraph 3.1 quote
it is proposed to change the name of the
district from bather to South Suffolk
and that quote if the name is changed
the formal name of the council would be
the District Council of South Suffolk
though it will usually be rendered as
itself Suffolk Council the
recommendation of paragraph 2.1 is quote
pursuant to section 74 Local Government
Act 1972 as amended to change the name
of the district from beta to South
Suffolk from the 1st of April 2020 end
of quotation however a report in the
East Anglian Daily Times on Tuesday 15th
October paid-for states that quote the
council's leaders have opted to cancel
the meeting and push back the debate to
give councillors more time to consider
it end of quotation
in the light of the above please one
name the councillors who quote
considered it relevant and timely to now
replace the name of baby with south
suffered quotation from the report at
paragraph 3.5 and identify the meeting
or meetings of which the decision to
propose the name change was made stating
where the minutes or record of such
meeting or meetings can be accessed
secondly state how many representations
respectively for and against the
proposal have been received and where
they can be accessed and thirdly state
whether any detailed assessment was made
of the financial costs of the proposed
rebranding specific to this council and
how it is proposed that cost will be
financed cuts award please could you
respond Thank You mr. lambing for your
question this looking at part 1 first of
all this first question really concerns
how policy ideas arise and get developed
and there are various informal
mechanisms and forums for this prior to
their being submitted formally to either
cabinet or Council as appropriate for
debate and voting specifically in this
case I originally raised the idea during
an informal cabinet discussion at a
during a workshop on the 22nd of July
2019 the topic of discussion was the
future rebranding for Baber
and mid Suffolk councils I therefore
took the opportunity to initially sound
out my cabinet colleagues about the idea
of changing the name of paper District
Council as this idea received in
principle indicative support from the
cabinet officers were tasked to draft a
relevant report as such a change
requires 2/3 of castles present at an
extrordinary council meeting to approve
it the report has not been taken to any
other committee there are of course no
minutes or records of the cameras
discussions at the workshop on 22nd of
July
2019 the second part we have received 8
formal responses 5 of them from
residents and parishes within
raising concerns about pronunciation the
proposed name history costs and
consultation and anonymized sub summary
of these can be produced on request one
of these from a Parish Council wasn't
against the proposal but wanted more
information and another missed the point
entirely thinking the proposal was to
change the spelling of Baber I and other
members have received a few emails as
well I have also had a mix of positive
and negative comments from my parish
councils about 50/50 whilst we always
consider feedback this doesn't and
cannot determine policy as it inevitably
only comes from a small number of
residents and it is usually only those
who strongly oppose something who
contact us I will say at this point that
the comments in the responses received
and also in the media concerning costs
and history have come from people who
clearly know little of either and I've
done the research for both of these
looking at the third part there is no
more detailed financial assessment of
the cost beyond what is contained in the
original report but based on experience
elsewhere it can be kept very low we are
in contact with in contact with and
learning from authorities who have done
this we will not change things that do
not need changing immediately and only
do it as things reach the end of life
and need replacing
Thank You Jenny thank you still I mean
do you have a supplementary yes I do
please thank you
Thank You councillor Ward for your
answer would you in fact not consider
that the public have been formally
consulted before proposing such a name
change and in view of your answer to
part 3 where you say we will not change
things that don't need changing
immediately and only do it
as things reach end-of-life and need
replacing but in the light of that would
you accept that there will be no need to
change the name of this council unless
and until it is involved in some form of
local government reorganisation
involving another council
and sword and tassel the first part in
terms of public consultation we here the
members here are representatives of the
public and they can consult through
through their local ward member as to
the second part local government
reorganization is not something that
it's currently under consideration
within the county and it would require
the cooperation of of other districts
and also the County Council itself
mr. lambing I believe you haven't a
second question thank you madam chairman
yes question second question for the
chairman of the Council Planning
Committee the question is this what were
the costs a incurred by the council and
be ordered to be paid by the council to
the claimant in the following legal
cases firstly the successful judicial
review challenged by mr. tigar to the
grant of Planning Commission by the
council on the 7th of February 2018
against the advice of its officers for a
housing development in the village of
hottest the granted permission being
quashed by the High Court by a consent
order made on the 15th of June 2018 on
the basis of the council's concession
made on the face of the order that it
had failed to supply adequate reasons
and secondly the second success of
challenge by mr. chair and here the
judgment is reported under the name
Queen on the application of gear against
favored district council 2019
EWH c220 for one admin the successful
challenge by mr. gay in that case was a
subsequent grant of planning permission
by the council on the 18th of December
2018 again against the advice of its
officers for the said development
judgment given on the 26th of july 2019
the basis of quashing the permission
again being the council's failure to
give reasons for its decision and quote
failure to determine whether or not and
the extent to which the development
proposal complied with the development
plan councillor beer please can you
respond thank you madam chairman thank
you for your question
the council's full in-house costs are
not possible to quantify whilst we could
prefer a details of the number of
officer hours spent on the matter for
our in-house legal team the time spent
by our planning team is not recorded and
the reality is that the officers
involved would have been employed by the
council in any event if not during the
work on these claims officers would have
been working on other council businesses
in terms of the voice and representation
I can sell we incurred 3,700 pounds
costs net of fat in relation to claim
one of June 2018 and thirteen thousand
four hundred and fifty pounds net of fat
in relation to claim - of july 2019 own
incidentals travelled to court proclaim
little to have mounted to 294 pounds and
seventy pence the council was ordered to
pay to the claimant costs of twelve
thousand 141 pounds 88 pence in relation
to claim one and thirty thousand pounds
in relation to clay
- thank you thank you madam chairman
mr. loving do you have a supplementary
it leave my comment first of all was I
retired from the bar too early my
question is this while it's entirely
proper for the planning committee in an
appropriate case to make a decision
contrary to the advice of its officers
and indeed often members of the public
from the local area wish it to do so
what listened however has the Planning
Committee learned from this costly
exercise and the figures that mr. beer
has just given amounted just under
60,000 pounds and what steps have been
or are being taken to seek to ensure
that such a reasons challenge against a
council decision cannot succeed in
future Thank You mr. lemming cuts the
beard you wish to respond thank you well
yes I think I can respond to that mr.
lemon certainly I think my planning
committee members take it very serious
when plan and applications come in front
of them and they are well aware that
costs can can go considerably high but
they are duty-bound to wired up in the
best way they feel they should and I
would hope the lesson that was learned
by my fellow plan committee members and
perhaps to all members of the council is
that be sure that you've got it correct
or that you know what you're voting on
and that you can have the evidence to
justify your decision thank you Thank
You Cal Sabir well now move on to item 7
questions by councillors in accordance
with council procedure rules Thank You
chair none received thank you
item 8b c 1923 overview in scrutiny
committee report I'd like to invite
counts um across to introduce his report
which is for noting the core Thank You
chair sorry I hit the wrong back the
joint overview and scrutiny committee
met on the 19th of September the report
is in front of you I won't go through
there are three main items we dealt with
community infrastructure levee the
expenditure framework review this is the
second year we've been examining this
more or less looking at how the
framework is developing in conjunction
with both the SIL team and the member
review panel I think the primary
exercise or primary part that you can
take from that report is that the nature
of SIL bits is changing and if that is
something like the draw members
particular attention to but we
thoroughly endorsed the work of both the
team and the joint member panel second
item was one that was brought up at
fairly short notice in discussing the
waste collection routes changes which
obviously received a great deal of
attention and some somewhat selective
use of statistics in the press in fact
when we actually examined the figures
the rate of missed collections even at
its very worse was still less than 1%
it has since fallen so those criticisms
there were problems in certain areas and
fundamentally the lesson here was that
if your bin was collected it was 100
percent successful if your bin was not
collected it was 100 percent failure we
thought that the process had been
carried out fairly and reasonably and we
asked for lessons to be learnt in any
future projects involving such a change
in any of our council activities and the
final item we looked at was an
information bulletin on the impact and
implementation of universal credit on
our own income management
in our housing services fundamentally
this is something we've been examining
progressively at the moment we can see
that the housing team have it in well
under control as much as it is possible
for something that not within our
control to be under control happy to
take any questions on the report and our
future work plans either within this
meeting or afterwards any questions to
cut some McCraw Thank You Council McCraw
Wright will now move on to item 9 BC
1924 corporate plan 20 2019 to 2027 I
would like to invite councillor Ward to
introduce paper BC 1924 and to move the
recommendation in the report Thank You
counsel would Thank You chairman as
colleagues on the cabinet are aware we
have been working on a cross-party basis
with our cabinet colleagues that mid
suffered for a new the existing joint
strategic plan before it expires in 2020
this work and the principles we have
developed to guide the evolution of the
corporate plan are set out in Appendix A
of your report a senior leadership team
has been supporting us in this work and
it has also been significant
significantly informed by officers from
across both councils and therefore
really proud to now be presenting than
this new joint corporate plan 2019 to
2027 on behalf of the cabinet for full
council approval of course the nature
and role of district castle's has not
fundamentally changed the new corporate
plan therefore reflects more of an
evolution rather than a revolution it
does however provide more stretching
joint vision for the future of our areas
and it is designed to enable us to
address the challenges and seize the
opportunities facing our districts and
our councils for the foreseeable future
the revised vision and the new mission
statement will ensure that we provide
more confident leadership of our places
through greater place-based working are
interconnected strategic priorities are
now firmly enshrined as being the
environment our economy housing
well-being our
customers and finally our communities
finally by embedding our new adopted
values within the corporate plan we are
more deeply rooting our organization in
what we believe in genuinely caring
about our residents and places and
getting stuff done for people a
visualization of the revised corporate
plan is contained within the report but
I have asked that the chief executive
provides more detailed PowerPoint
presentation which he will do once the
motion has been moved and seconded I
therefore take great pleasure in moving
the recommendation to paragraph 3.1 the
council adopts the draft corporate plan
2019 to 2027 to Council as visually
represented in paragraph 4.5 to replace
the refresh joint strategic plan 2016 to
2020 and may I have a seconder
cutter RC did you want to say anything
thank you so we'll now move on to
questions in debate oh oh sorry
presentation thank you thank you members
and as the leader has already set out
the key points I'm just going to try and
take you through a little bit of the
detail as they leader said a bit of more
of a detailed summary I warn you now
there are 22 slides to this detailed
summary and a short film but but bear
with me you should all have in front of
you a hard copy of that conscious that
you won't be able to see on the screen
the exact wording and so it produced you
a larger hard copy although for those of
you working on your tablets you can of
course zoom in on those as well if you
prefer so to take you through what I'm
largely going to talk you through is
Appendix A to the report and then
specifically through the diagrams but
firstly taking you through what is
Appendix A so this document replaces as
you've heard the previous joint
strategic plan that's a document the run
to some 30 pages and that we've had both
a refreshed version and then the
original version for a number of years
now and I'll take you through some of
the principles that sit behind that but
the new version contains more it's a lot
shorter it's only one diagram but it
contains more than those original 30
pages did in particular what I wanted to
do at the outset is just set out what we
mean by vision mission values and
strategy
because you're gonna see those forwards
a lot or you're gonna hear those
followed words a lot so by vision
specifically what we're talking about
there is describing the world that we
want to see for Baber and for mid
Suffolk this being a joint plan the
mission therefore is then an extension
of that so it's not the vision it's not
the world we want to see but it's
specifically the wrong that this council
plays in making that vision become a
reality if I just pause at that stage
that mission statement that concept of a
mission isn't something that was
contained within the previous
incarnation of the joint strategic plan
at the corporate plan and was a
significant gap in my opinion because
what it meant was you had a vision
statement if I go to that one for Baber
and one for mid Suffolk but you had no
roadmap particularly for officers but
also for councilors to show what role we
play in actually delivering that vision
you just simply had a very broad
overarching statement so the mission
helps describe how we will go about
making that vision of reality we then
have values that set out the motivation
behind that vision the heart as you see
there behind the mission and describe
what drives us as people as individuals
but as organizations so describing that
those culture and those values that sit
behind us including our behaviors and
then finally specific strategies their
tactics if you like there's - not what
we're going to do but how do we intend
to go forth and make these things a
reality so those four words you're going
to see appearing a number of times but
it was useful to set those out and as I
say compared to the previous incarnation
the previous version had two visions not
one and it did have mention of
strategies but it had no mission and
critically also had no values and so
those are the changes in a nutshell that
have come forward through the the
revised corporate plan so just touching
briefly on the values these aren't new
hopefully they're not new to you they've
been in place since the start of the
year so I'm not going to spend much time
talking about them in detail that's
probably useful to do at a different
session but but as you know hopefully we
have those five values in place they're
hanging around my neck through the
lanyard that I've got and we've gone a
constant process of embedding those
values into what everything that we do
as an
organization similarly many of the
strategies are already in place so we
already have a leisure sport and
physical activity strategy that was
adopted back in autumn at 2017 an
economic strategy more commonly known as
open for business customer strategy
community strategy homes and housing
strategy and an emerging environment
strategy that's not one that's currently
in place but that's one that the new
task force is working on and some work
began even before you adopted the
climate change emergency work began on
this prior to the elections as well you
can see there the dates that each have
been adopted the key thing I wanted to
just highlight in relation to those six
strategies and I'll come back to them
again later is the environment one as I
say is very much a work in progress that
isn't there yet so what you're seeing
when you see the corporate plan is not a
finished piece of work but the start of
further work the economic strategy your
assistant director Fiona that wishes to
revisit that that's as you see as you
saw earlier a couple of years old now
and so she will be revisiting that with
the cabinet members in due course during
the course of the year to make sure that
we have the most relevant economic
strategy for what are constantly
changing economic times and then lastly
just to mention in terms of this slide
you'll have seen if I just flick back
briefly you'd have seen we've got in
place a leisure sports and physical
activity strategy very much a sport
strategy what we don't have is a health
and well-being strategy and we add the
aspiration to turn that from just being
about sports to being all things health
and well-being that much in the same way
that everything that we Commission is
also about health and well-being as well
so in terms of the strategies while as
many are in place they're on a journey
as well and you can see it you will see
that these start to evolve further
particularly those three over the course
of the next 12 months the key thing I
would say about strategies if I just
focus on this ever so slightly and if I
use an analogy if I use a football
analogy which is dangerous for me I know
very little about football but if you
think about football the team whichever
team you choose to support will change
its tactics on a weekly basis possibly
during the game depending upon who
they're playing against local government
has a habit of adopting strategies and
Lee
in place for four five six seven years
as the world changes around us and our
tactics don't change so my anticipation
is that whilst we should have these in
place these should be much more lively
live documents that are constantly kept
onto a review is to is the tactic
working and if it's not then obviously
changing accordingly moving on to the
meat then what I wanted to focus on is
the vision as I say the world we want to
see and our part in making that become a
reality and through the cabinet in
conjunction with their colleagues as the
leader has said at mid Suffolk we've
been working prior to the election and
subsequently to develop the concepts
that you'll see set out within Appendix
A so what's important to achieve through
having a revised corporate plan first
and foremost having a single and that's
critical as I've said already previously
we had a joint vision makes life very
difficult when they've got that subtlety
subtly joint vision but they were only
subtly different clear and compelling
vision that inspires common purpose and
I'll revisit the vision in a moment
again that it should reflect paper and
mid Suffolk as places this shouldn't be
a corporate plan that you can cut and
paste that apply to any other rural
district elsewhere in England it should
be as relevant as we can possibly make
it to our districts recognizing of
course the district councils tend and
Borough Council's tend to provide the
same services so you would expect to
some degree of general our general arity
that there should be a golden thread and
again if I use the slightly hackneyed
now anecdote that you may have heard
previously man walks into Nasser sees a
cleaner sweeping the floor asked him
what he does for a living and that man
says I'm putting a man on the moon that
principle should apply to everything
what we do as well there should be their
golden thread all the way through from
the vision to every single individual
officers one to one's appraisals their
objectives on an annual basis it's not
just about providing a high level vision
it's about making that connection to
absolutely everything that we do that it
should be along the term plan but it's
very nature that's not something you're
gonna want to keep chopping and changing
all the time but we are our course in
the electoral body we do have elections
every four years so the recommendation
is that it should be refreshed and
reviewed just before and then
immediately prior to each of our
district council elections
and and I cast across it as and when
there's a general election as well
because that tends to result in a change
in our environment the broader
environment with each we're within which
we operate and need to make sure again
that our tactics are appropriate and
that our corporate plan is appropriate
to that change the world and then lastly
in terms of this slide and probably
again it's quite significant in terms of
the change this corporate plan is our
unashamedly for you for our stakeholders
and for our staff apologies to mr.
lemming at the back it's not for the
public in that regard that doesn't mean
we should be communicating with the
public it doesn't mean that we should be
making very clear what our vision is for
our residents for our taxpayers but the
document itself is about making us the
efficient organization that we need to
be to deliver what you are looking for
for the future building further on
what's important the vision should feel
beyond reach that shouldn't simply be a
case that you can stand on the doorstep
whichever political party you represent
in four years time and be able to say
yes we've achieved this tick that box
aren't we great no the vision is
deliberately at the leaders and the
cabinet's requests something that should
feel constantly that little bit out of
reach should be a stretch for us in that
regard but more broadly the vision in a
nutshell is about improving quality of
life I would argue that's what we exist
for as local government and particularly
what we exist for as District Council's
the plan clearly should align and I will
revisit this when we come to the image
itself the plan should align to our
emerging local plan there's no point
having a local plan that sets out a
blueprint for our districts for the next
18 years if our corporate plan is
telling us something completely
different there clearly needs to be some
alignment between the two but as ice'
mentioned already we've moved from a 30
page document the aspiration is to be a
plan on the page just the document the
diagram that you have in front of you
but supported by digital materials hence
the video that I'm going to play for you
shortly the plan will also then inform
those strategies so it's a it's a
symbiotic relationship between the
strategies that I talked about and again
I've talked about some other strategies
shortly and equally to inform them as
they emerge
so should be constantly flowing back and
forth and as I said already there should
be multiple methods for communicating to
the residents to our public to our
taxpayers to our customers that what our
vision mission and those strategic
priorities are equally cabinet is
considered what the plan should not be
very well talking about what it should
be but equally what it shouldn't be and
so the proposal is that we shouldn't
adopt a single approach as a district
council you may be familiar with other
councils elsewhere in the country that
the easy model the easy council model
similar to easyJet's where you get a
basic service with anything else you
have to pay extra for a commissioning
council which very much splits the
council in half so you have a
commissioning function that decides what
it wants and then it commissions those
services often from other bits of the
council sometimes from elsewhere and so
on and so forth the view is that no we
are complicated and complex sometimes
chaotic organization as a local
government or body as local government
and therefore having a single model
simply doesn't work we need to be more
flexible than that having said that the
local plaque the corporate plan so I
should provide some boundaries as to
what we aren't not just say what we will
do but what we aren't should it be style
over substance and shouldn't always
include or shouldn't include try to
include the context within which we
operate because that context moves very
quickly and as I've said already the
intention is that the local plan the
corporate plan sorry should be here for
with us for a longer period of time in
developing it we've also focused and
you'll see mention in a moment of
various sessions with officers so being
engaged where they believe I just click
forward a hundred and six staff over the
course of a series of events during the
course of this year and whilst this is
looking at what we should be for the
future that's very much what the
corporate plan is about it's also
recognising we shouldn't lose what makes
us great already and so you'll see here
the suggestions the views of our staff
echoed by our cabinet councillor
colleagues as to what's important about
what we already do this is building on
what we already do this is a if you're
like an evolution rather than a
revolution in that regard so caring for
our districts our sense of duty of
friendliness and welcome this approach
that been greater than the sum of our
parts the richness and strengtheneth
entity authenticity of our relationships
our local knowledge of our places our
essential links to our communities how
we are seen to value those communities
and being custodians for them and
improving our places whilst protecting
their character and strengths are all
things that staff say are critically
important and that we do already doesn't
mean we can't do more off but the read
already and the therefore should be
preserved as part of the development of
this new corporate plan so it's said
already that's come through staff that's
come through extended leadership team
the senior leadership team and then
through joint cabinet discussions with
mid Suffolk cabinet as well but in a
nutshell that the corporate plan should
be about quality of life that over
arches everything it's about ambition
and aspiration prosperity and valuing
our places and reflecting and I would
argue respecting the historical
qualities that make up our places as
well so if I take you now on to the
actual diagram itself and you need to
think of this a bit like a dartboard so
we're starting from the middle and
working outwards that's the best way of
trying to visualize this and so a focus
first and foremost on the vision so
through all of that work that's
culminated in this vision statement
building great communities with bright
and healthy futures that everyone is
proud to call home that's the vision the
world we want to see supported by the
mission as I said how we'll go about
creating that as baby district council
so we'll provide strong proud
inspirational leadership striving for
excellence and together building great
communities for everyone to live work
visit and invest in so that's the vision
and mission at the center of everything
that we're trying to achieve and then
support it around that as I said already
is the local plan so apologies to
planning colleagues if they're in the
room sometimes planning the local plan
can be seen as a planning document my
view is East is not or it is as also a
planning document more fundamentally as
I said already
it's the blueprint for our districts for
the next 18 years it sets out what our
places should look like for the next 18
years and therefore should be at the
center of that diagram supporting the
the mission that's why you see slap bang
in the middle as we then spread out
through the diagram there are six
strategic priorities each of which
underpinned by a strategic us by a
strategy itself and I've mentioned those
stretches itself already but those are
strategic priorities for us they're not
rocket science they won't come as a
surprise to you a purchase to run
through them so the environment
communities well-being customers housing
and economy they are deliberately drawn
that way in a circle because they all
relate to one another we can't do
something in the economy without
thinking about the environment and our
communities we can't do something in
relation to well-being without thinking
what that might mean in terms of housing
communities and so on and so forth so
they are of equal weight in this model
no one is more important or less
important than the others in that regard
what's proposed is that they should be
seen as a whole as six strategic
priorities none of this happens though
without people so very well talking
about documents is all very well having
pretty pictures and models but
ultimately we're a people business
within local government nothing happens
without all of you as our councillors
but also not without all of our staff
and then with our public as well
so those things that look a little bit
like corporates they're supposed to look
like people our reflection of where our
people sit in amongst the entirety of
this corporate plan and then also I have
to mention them already are values that
wrap all the way around the outside of
everything that we do driving what we're
doing in terms of how we go about
approaching things it's not just what we
do day to day but it's how we go about
doing it in terms of our culture in
terms of our behaviors and our
engagement with all these components and
then lastly in terms of their diagram
and I won't read them out because you've
got them in front of you but in terms of
joining up that golden thread as I said
already you'll see their bottom
right-hand side in the in the light
green appraisals and 1 2 once that's the
link all the way back to every single
thing that every single officer is doing
within the organization and next to it
that within the sort of lighter blue the
people strategy as well but there are
nuts and bolts the organizational
strategies that we have to have the
medium-term financial strategy the asset
strategy and so on and so forth the form
part and parcel of making sure that
we're a solid organization a
to deliver the things that you want us
to deliver so that's the corporate plan
in a nutshell I did have a short film
the film isn't specifically for the
corporate plan it was produced as part
of our wider materials both through a
recruitment and for our staff conference
earlier in the year but it's relevant
and you'll see it's a good example of
the types of digital material that will
go alongside essentially what is a
one-page diagram so if I just play that
briefly for you
[Music]
from first light we start working a
[Music]
brand mid Suffolk are really great
places with fantastic Bright Futures but
what's even more important than what
makes them fantastic other people the
residents and the tenants that will work
for our councillors who volunteer their
time to our communities and all of our
staff were incredibly proud and
passionate who care about their
communities and making them even better
for the future everyone deserves a safe
warm home we're working hard to build
new homes and create settled communities
to help our residents live happy and
healthy lives we've helped thousands of
families with our home select scheme and
helped return over 300 previously empty
homes back into use
we're working to make paper amid Suffolk
communities healthier happier and safer
places to live we've committed millions
of pounds to replace enough herbage
much-loved community assets such as
village halls community centers play
areas and sports facilities through
funding advice and grants we support
hundreds of projects like this new skate
park in Sudbury so that communities can
revitalize their local area keeping
Baber and mid Suffolk clean and litter
free is really important to us our teams
and lots of volunteers go out and click
thousands of tonnes of waste and
recycling every year customers come
first for us that's the bottom line our
customer service staff know Baber and
mid Suffolk really well we've created
new service points across our district
with faizon's of business one of our
most important jobs is securing the
right type of house in the right place
it's not just about new homes
we're helping local businesses set up
with the right facilities in the right
places
this creates jobs for our residents and
supports our economy
this is how way helping to make vapor
amid Stafford great places that people
want to call home at the end of the day
we're all about preserving what's
fantastic in Weber amid suffer making
bright futures for all of our residents
and ensuring that everyone is proud to
call us home
[Music]
what was that
you'll be pleased that I'm not gonna
play one of those so I've got one more
slide which hopefully will come up
technology willing there we go
and so just in terms of the video that
video was produced during the course
early part of the summer but clearly was
informed by some of this work so you'll
notice some of the commonality in terms
of the language the critical thing for
me in relation to that production is it
were that piece of material is you're
not in it and you should be but you're
not in it because we haven't yet agreed
or you haven't yet approved to the
corporate plan so once that's done then
clearly we will produce similar digital
materials that would incorporate all of
our counselors in it as well hopefully
that was always already familiar to you
you may well have seen some of it
because it's been playing on the screens
in endeavor house for a number of weeks
now if not months so hopefully it wasn't
a shock to see that there and lastly
from me and the last of my slides it's
just to talk about what comes next
that's not wishing to predetermine your
decisions tonight but if you do approve
the corporate plan and if mid Suffolk
does approve the corporate plan on
Thursday then the next immediate step is
the top of that diagram you can see
their corporate outcomes 2019 to 2023
effectively I've kind of loosely called
that the senior leadership team service
plan so alongside every other service
plan that we have for each different
services of the organization there are
some clear corporate outcomes that we
would wish to adopt for that four-year
window and the proposal is that they
will come through to cabinet for the
next available cabinet meeting but
clearly they can't come through until
the corporate plan itself the
overarching document has been considered
and approved and I'll stop and stop at
that point
thank you thank you talkie fix XT for
that presentation and I'd now like to
open this up to questions and debate
Jenny I like to start cuts or Lindsey
thank you thank you for the presentation
and quite impressed actually and I
particularly liked the line about
quality of life for residents I think
that's really important and should be at
the heart of what a council should be
about my worry and I'm sorry I normally
like to share these things in advance
but it's only really occurred to me as
we were going through the presentation
it's the use of the word customer and
not the use of the word citizen because
we're not a corporate body we're not
just the corporate body some things we
do are corporate but at the heart of
what we do has to be civic pride a
public surface ethos were a public
sector body and as you rightly said are
sort of almost are poor mission is to
improve the quality of life for our
citizens or our residents not our
customers because if you see as you
won't use the word customers you're
getting into that mindset where we're
trying to get some money out of them and
and I feel that could be a mistake for
when we're trying to generate a sense of
civic pride a public service ethos in
what is public sector body with publicly
elected representatives so I guess I'm
saying if we can change that word to
citizens I'll happily approve it but as
it stands I'm not sure I will actually
thank you thank you
cuts award I'm pleased
Kathlyn see that you are in favor
generally of the corporate plan I'm
concerned that you're going to withhold
your support just based on that one word
and citizens residents customers I think
using the word customer does actually
say something it shows that yes we are a
public service body and there is the
public service ethos but nonetheless we
have to start thinking about how we can
incorporate private sector concepts of
delivering service to customers
customer satisfaction and I think in
that context the use of the word
customer is valid here I don't mind the
word resident I do have a bit of an
objection to citizen perhaps but but
nonetheless I think customer is right
because it says a lot about what we're
trying to achieve and the way we want to
achieve it got some of a Z thank you
madam chairman I share counsel Awards
opinion I think we should talk with
customers because what we're about is
the exchange of mutual values to mutual
satisfaction so once we get that concept
then we'll start to deliver but the
other thing I wanted to mention madam
chairman is to say thank you to everyone
for putting the environment in the info
graph but also to moving it up the
agenda because our attitude to the
environment moving forward will affect
our economy and will affect the quality
of life so I'd like to say thank you for
moving it up the agenda thank you Thank
You Council of AZ council Parker Thank
You Chet yeah I would also like to say
that we shouldn't be afraid of the word
customer because we're not just talking
about our communities we're talking
about the organization organization as a
whole and all of us are customers and if
we're talking about customers the
connotation is service and how well do
we service everybody within our
organization so that's our communities
that's us as counselors what is our
relationship with our offices and our
agents as well one of the big drivers
for me as portfolio holder behind that
the whole customer portfolio is our
culture around how we deliver to our
communities and how we are perceived and
at the moment that stock I think
reasonably we could say is fairly low so
we have to drive that up we have to make
that better we must not get bogged down
with simple phrases we keep that in mind
we're talking about customer's service
how much better can we do for everybody
that engages with us so I'm quite
comfortable that I'm quite comfortable
as it is I'm Jeff thank you
Thank You counsel Parker Cutler Davis
yeah I'm pretty much happy to endorse
what has just been said about the word
customer I certainly prefer to the word
citizen which to me has very much George
Orwell 1984 feel about it we're here to
serve our communities our residents our
people our customers the broad range
this vision does that it encompasses as
much as we can say I'm more than happy
to support this council her
thank you madam chairman
unlike Arthur I am do you have a great
love of football and I can do soccer
analogies all all night long and Arthur
haven't had the team taught which sounds
very good are you confident that we can
deliver I will support the plan but I do
have some very grave misgivings about
our performance already and it's alright
making promises for apple pie but given
that some of what you talked about is
statutory duties anyway I would hope
that in the future if a community comes
to you with reports of a legal planning
in an area of extender of natural beauty
continuous extensive environmental
breaches and many other things that the
team will deliver and not continue to
leak very big own goals I think there's
some people in this room know what I'm
talking about
and I think before we start playing
pretty football we ought to get the
defense correct to start with thank you
Thank You counselor her
any other comments
so yes cuts award have you anything else
you'd like to add
no chairman thank you in that case all
those in favor that's that's carried
anyone against thank you one again just
thank you that's carried item 10b C 1924
political balance and composition of
committees I'd like to invite general
Burson deputy monitoring officer to
introduce paper BC 1924 Thank You Jan
Thank You chair and members are asked to
approve the revised political balance
and composition of committees for the
council as a result of the recent
decision by councillors Aires and Mabry
to join the independent group this will
ensure that the council meets its legal
obligations under the local government
and Housing Act 1989 thank you could I
have a proposal please
councillor Ward and the Second Earth
Council RC thank you all those in favor
that's courage unanimous I think now
we'll move on to item 11 election of a
vice chair for overview and scrutiny
committee may have nominations for the
vice chair really be in scrutiny
committee are you proposing cancel award
yes I'd like to nominate proposed
councillor Adrienne Osborne for the role
of vice-chair of overview scrutiny
committee Adrienne has served on on the
committee for some time now and would be
a very able person to take over that
role thank you cats award can I have a
seconder please Thank You council McCraw
did you want to say anything
thank you any other nominations thank
you all those in favor that's carried
unanimously thank you councillor
appointments are there any changes
servant on a punt order
I don't know that was Karen animistic
I'm sorry can we go back to that then
were there any any against in that last
item please
any abstentions
ah two abstentions okay can we update
uh-huh could you have those mated please
thank you
Thank You councillor beer right we'll
move on to item 12
then councillor appointments so are
there any changes to those already
tabled in item 10 understand not so
those in favor don't need to do that
right fine okay we'll move on to the
motor on notice
item 13
right I'd like the monitoring deputy
monitoring officer to say a few words
Thank You members before we commence a
debate on the motion like to point out
that this relates to a cabinet function
therefore once this has been duly moved
seconded and debated this will be
referred to cabinet for decision the
comments from this debate will be
referred to cabinet for them to take
into account when considering the motion
as per part three fourteen point seven
of the Constitution thank you I'd like
to invite counsel via to move the motion
please thank you thank you madam
chairman when we all have the motion in
front of you you don't wish me to read
that all out right then that's in front
of you I just like to propose that and
speak now or to members this motion
would give us as members the opportunity
to get involved and to call on the
public to come up with suggestions and
solutions as how to we should go forward
I'm a clear voice or friend of the
motorist that's fine but we also need to
hear the voice of the green agenda and
other road users and safety
organizations there are as we know many
problems in our major tangle of
suffering after long delays the removal
of parking spaces in cross street and
very soon be underway and will help
improve the air quality for residents of
cross street as the result of growth and
visitors in the future our car parks are
quite often full and that may mean that
we
need and this means that we may just
need better minor works such as line
markings tying limits or residence
parking permits we should not rule in or
out at lookin at a multi-story car park
or new improved car parks or other ideas
throughout the district
we will be losing parking spaces if we
get the real in the market he'll read
the bus stops and civil parking
enforcement which could force more cars
to park in our side streets and cause
residential and environmental problems
their growth and visitors happen also in
other parts of Baber district because we
are open for business that's our slogan
hadley maybe copeland at the moment but
with the increased development happening
in and around Hadley there may be a need
to identify a new parking areas or other
solutions our Taurus air is long Mel
that left not as well as other areas
perhaps needs to be looked at to see how
we can improve car parking and the flow
of traffic flows in our small villages
and communities members we need to have
a fresh new approach and clear open
minds to investigate this I'd like the
cabinet to take action as soon as
possible and set up a small group to
report back thank you Thank You
councillor beer could I have a seconder
for the motion please cut so Newman did
you want to speak yeah I'll just say
I'll be pleased to second this and I
reserve the right to speak later thank
you
Oh counselor Lindsay had a thank you
chair yes I'd like to move an amendment
to that it's motion it's now the right
time to do it should i stir speak to it
yes you can
sure yeah I mean thank you for bringing
this and I agree with everything you
said in your introductory moving the
motion there it is we do need to agree
we do need a review of parking my only
problem with the original motion is
there's a couple of assumptions there
that the answer is more parking so the
words extra capacity so we take I've
taken the word extra out but what level
of capacity will be needed because it
swings and roundabouts we can't look at
car drivers in isolation and we've had
as I shared without members this study
from 2011 people said oh it's all out of
date well we need to provide it because
what it recommends in there it looks at
the actual figures and we need to look
at that but if you look just take sub B
on and load it alone which is probably I
think now severe would agree is probably
where that but the biggest parking
issues are perhaps they make the point
that there are around if you look at the
people that are driving in Sudbury 43
percent of them are driving to work are
within already lived within submarine
and cornered so they're driving less
than 2 kilometers that 1 plus 1 and a
quarter miles on it in old money so they
don't need to actually drive there isn't
a need for path analysis for those
people there's a need to encourage them
to use other forms of transport like the
old feet like a bicycle even like a bus
and we need to look at ways to fund
buses and those other bits of
infrastructure there's not just low
so hence up a review car and cycle
parking if this is also an even worse
shortage of psychopaths if you look at
the provision that they at the station
in Sudbury it's appalling it's long is
identified eleven the problem nothing's
been done about it I know what the other
amendments are putting is that the thing
we need to consider is the change to
electric vehicles and there's going to
be a need not just for parking spaces
but for charging points for those
vehicles as well so I urge you to accept
this amendment thank you Thank You
counsel NZ have you got a second counts
them across thank you did you want to
say anything counselor cause I reserve
the right to speak later thank you cups
of beers do you accept this amendment
thank you madam chairman I think we're
going to agree on this but I do think
your plan with words with the extra
because I do think there will be extra
demand if all these other factors happen
I apologize they're not added in cyclin
a cycle division I did think about it
but I did think well the O cyclin that
I'm likely to will be on an electric
bicycle but I I take that point
certainly certainly rather than in the
uptake in the use of electric vehicles
yes I should have thought of that one
and I accept that quite happily I'm just
a little bit concerned with the word
extra because there will be extra
demands because of a Levine's beador but
you know I don't know whether you
particularly want to keep remove that
word I would like it to stay that the
other two points are more than happy
today
that's a Lindsay please could you reply
to this question sure yeah I I would
like to remove that word extra because I
think it's goes to the heart of the
issue here there's an assumption in this
motion that more houses automatically
means we have to provide more parking
for it and I think we shouldn't if we're
doing a review of barking we shouldn't
go into that review with that assumption
we need to think about how we can
encourage shift people out of cars into
a sustainable transport so I'm sorry I
don't think I want to keep the extra
councillor beer you need to decide now
whether you would like to accept the
amendment or not well I'm looking around
the room and I see my friends off a
certain my friends behind me is beside
me I'm quite sure I'll be proven right
that we will need extra but I will
remove that word so that we can move
forward provide my second to accept so
thank you thank you can't sleep here
so now we'll open it up to Sue's
counselling Oh cut some new and do you
accept this Thank You councillor Newman
will now move on to discussion a debate
thank you cuts the ward Thank You
chairman III do have a lot of sympathy
with Casa Lindsay's desires to see a
modal shift particularly in those
residents who live relatively close to
our town centres indeed I've spoken to
Cassandra Clements here and she is
currently looking into the feasibility
and cost associated with cycle secure
cycle storage in hopefully the
kingfishers car park in in Sudbury in
terms of other encouragement it does
require us to work very closely with
Suffolk County Council because
we are very much dependent upon them
particularly with regard to bus routes
and and also the provision of cycle
length lanes whether they are
appropriate and feasible I also have a
lot of sympathy with castle piers
statement that he will be proven right
in the end in that extra capacity will
be needed
quite simply there's going to be a lot
of development taking place in
communities a long way from our major
towns and with the best will in the
world those people are going to want and
need rather to drive to Sudbury to
Hadley we don't want to discourage that
prevent them from doing so we want them
into those towns to support the
businesses we don't want them to go to
coaches to bury or it's rich but also
the other last point I'd like to make is
that crucially this isn't just about
something heavy and I know we've
mentioned Lavenham long Melford et
cetera but there are other places where
we know that there are problems problems
with parking pin mill capacity at
certain times of the year is is limited
and and the demand exceeds the capacity
and with the best woman world there
won't be any alternative for people of
them to drive to pin mill we do have
problems in villages such as cables that
marry and again I can't see that a modal
shift is going to seriously have an
impact there it does need extra parking
provision in that village and finally of
course although Denham is outside of
district the parking problems in Dedham
are increasing year upon year and they
take place in Baber north of the river
alongside the road leading to rapid and
merry the county has put in double
yellow lines that those that restriction
is very often flatted because there's no
enforcement but at some point we are
going to have to seriously consider some
parking provision there for the tourists
today them Thank You chairman Thank You
council Ward cut some of AZ thank you
madam chairman there has been mention of
Lavenham along Melford both of which are
very strong tourist destinations and
they earn quite a substandard a make a
big contribution to the
onami of Bieber one of the issues well
like everybody else parking is a problem
I can speak for long Melford because I
represent the ward the neighborhood plan
steering committee conducted a survey on
top of the agenda was parking and the
issue of cars in the village
it is a conservation area so we are
restricted as is Suffolk County with
what they can do
everybody's spoken of the different
aspects but one thing that we've ignored
is the lack of consideration of drivers
and the need to educate drivers to not
be so selfish and to consider other
people and I think that with civil
parking enforcement coming in in the new
year hopefully these inconsiderate Drive
card owners drivers will be hit hard in
the pocket and they will then learn to
park and to use their cars more sensibly
Thank You Madame
thank you cuts it cuts across well being
a shopping resident I think the main
thing at the moment is to get you
enforcement the traffic sorted you won't
have a real idea how much traffic you
can have in the town and how the car
parks are used because at the moment you
just got people park and wherever they
want in the town so until they my shoes
are sorted out and you get your
enforcement done I don't really think
how much extra pollen you might need
because people pop now even if it's a
three hour stay all day because there's
no need to move so that may change
things all together Thank You councillor
crows well councillor Fraser thank you
madam chairman I think that's I think
I'll speak a little bit about Hadley of
course if I may and I think the Hadley
no it is certainly I believe it's got a
special High Street and it's a High
Street which is continuously evolving
and it is changing I certainly welcome
this motion because I think certainly we
need a review that is important and
looks concurrently at civil parking
enforcement and to measure the
subsequent parking requirements within
the town and parking along the high
street and the offshoots
should be examined how best to serve
businesses as well as residents and
visitors alike including cyclists of
course is one of the one of the many
cafe
stopped off points for a Sunday cycle
right so that's pretty important as well
there's many proposed developments and
current developments man had leap which
okay we've debated is that going to
increase in traffic it's likely it will
although we don't want it to but I'm
also conscious that Hadleys also going
to be losing some parking capacity with
the development of corks length hence
why it's important really to look at the
future of our Hadley high street and the
environs there i think it's an ideal
opportunity to align this review with
Hadleys own vision for the prosperity
and offend plymouth if it's implemented
with maybe future high street funding
monies as they pinch potential force and
great improvement for the benefits of
businesses residents and visitors alike
so I certainly involved this I certainly
support this motion and I'd like to see
certainly the town businesses residence
and the Town Council of course all
involved in moving this forward thank
you
because the Frazer cuts to Jameson Oh
oh sorry
um I think sorry okay
I'd like to just raise an issue with
something councillor Ward mentioned he
said some worst effect if we've all the
were in the world the only alternative
is to drive the pin mill I love six
miles little pin well and I ride there
relatively recently frequently on my
bicycle and what I would like is bad
cycling parking facilities a pin mill
and of the places of interest around the
district Thank You councillor Hardacre
kalsa Horan Thank You chairman well I
would like to concur with a councillor
Mel VZ said the parking is appalling
that we don't have parking anymore we
have abandonment in some cases it's
horrendous absolutely horrendous but I
think we need look more towards the
county for a steer because everything at
the moment is pushing people into their
cars on the road we have the disastrous
school transport policy which in my area
will probably put no less than 20 more
cars on the road now I realized when
they get to that destination they won't
use public car parks but they certainly
will park where they can in the case of
Boxford school they partner up to the
bypass now I know it's not strictly what
we're talking about tonight but it is
all part of the same problem and also
the cuts in bus services also sending
more people into the car some people
cannot drive for various reasons but
those that can until they have to give
up use of the car take it all the more
and we are creating a car Society
possibly a bit to what we were talking
about earlier we should be trying to
create a car less Society in many
is possible but we have to be alert to
the changes that are not helping our
cause in any way at all
Thank You counsel heron Kelso Gold thank
you madam chair
as the ward councillor for pin mail I
would like to echo what counsel Hardacre
here has said it is difficult to park at
pin Mill it's not impossible at times I
was very pleased that counts an award
actually brought the shot he needs to
have into the debate because sometimes
we can feel a little bit isolated at
that end of Baber but it is also a
wonderful example of how people do think
creatively and do think outside the box
those of us who live not many miles from
pin Mill can't take our cars down there
in park so we do walk we do cycle we do
car share we do think creatively because
who wouldn't want to arrive at the
button oyster thank you Thank You
counselor called kalsa Busbee Thank You
Jay I'm a bit disappointed by this it
really in the way that he it started out
I think it's time that we've got to
think about public transport we've got
huge amounts of potential developments
and we know that if we allow that
development to go ahead our roads will
become car parks which is maybe what
you're after I don't know but the roads
are already a car part if we allow 500
extra houses a year for the next 20
years what are we going to be left with
and I'm sorry for anything
we shouldn't be worth waiting for the
County Council to come up with a
solution to this
I think they've proved that they failed
quite considerably to deliver a solution
on public transport I think it's time
that the Baber district and maybe bits
of it should grab this one and run with
it we've got to come up with a solution
which delivers a better public transport
system whether it's buses feet or worse
cycles and this tends to imply that
those three things aren't as important
to finding car parking spaces
we've all got car
buttons John mentioned cable we've got
potentially another 750 houses where
will they pop when they go to the shop
well maybe they'll have to walk it
doesn't mean we should provide car
parking spaces we've had parking
problems in Pinewood since suffered one
was built what 15 years ago it doesn't
mean that we should build a car park in
Suffolk in Pinewood now maybe we should
look at where these people come from and
provide an alternative transport system
when that's College was built County
Council had a green transport policy
that was wonderful it lasted one year
we've got to expect that people will use
cars where they have to but we've got to
encourage them out of these cars I'm
surprising is that you weren't more
emphatic on on that Thank You kalsa
Busby Council John Osborne thank you
madam chairman I welcome this motion in
particular cross street I'm glad to see
that bather and County are now working
together to deliver some solutions for
that particular problem they've suffered
long enough in that particular street so
I really welcome that I look forward to
civil parking enforcement being
introduced but at the same token I do
appreciate that it will solve some
problems but it will create some new
ones so it will need some creative
thinking from the cabinet members
working together with supper to come up
with some solutions on how we can
deliver better public transport for
example as David David Busby's referred
to cycling routes although I do have to
say I don't think I'd fantasy cycling
through Sudbury at the moment unless
I've got a high insurance policy but I'm
sure Adrian would be glad about but we
would need to look at that level of
traffic before you could put some cycle
routes in there I won't cover our rural
areas but we do need councillor Ward has
already covered that we do need to bear
in mind that yes we do have parking
problems in Sudbury and in Hadley but
also our rural
locations are also suffering from this
so I really welcome this and I look
forward to some really creative thinking
coming forward on how these issues can
be resolved and we can move on
thank you I'm Kim Thank You counselors
for cuts uh McCraw thank you madam chair
I'll just because I was thinking the
amendment I'm not sure where we are
because it's if we get all the
amendments been accepted so is a
substantive motion in fact so we're just
getting straight to the point and the
reason I really in supported the
amendment and and glad it's been accept
it is because I note from the original
resolution original motion that we have
recently closed down parking spaces to
improve pollution and improve the
traffic flow now we've been just
recently adopted and launched a raft of
environmental strategies and policies
and it seems a little bizarre having
just closed down some parking spaces for
a good solid environmental and health
reasons that we automatically assume we
have to add more now I speak here is a
lifelong non driver so I've had to use
public transport
Krim creative use of catching lists but
there's otherwise known as car sharing
and that many members in the chamber
would have had the opportunity to give
me a lift at Barry phone as I begged
from them to get you from A to B but it
makes more sense we have not examined
these possibilities or nothing we it's
every time we see a planning application
there's a there's a transport plan
produced which which always says car
sharing are going to be carpooling I
think I'd love to see it actually
seriously applied and actually make when
planning applications come forward make
it a condition they actually do some
carpooling because the major method I
have a mode of transport is the cycle
that's been referred to by so many
people and as it's been referred to by
councillors Osborn and Osborn Sudbury is
not an easy place to cycle I've cycled
in every single part of something at
some time or another and supper II is my
least favorite place it's not just the
road network it's the volume of traffic
anything we can do because there's a
safety aspect there's no question about
it that in itself is a reason
to be cutting down on the amount of road
movements Road vehicle movements yes
electronic hikes I think we'll all go
that way one day I'm certainly likely to
at some time in the next 10 or 15 maybe
20 years hasn't happened yet a man a man
can dream I know I know I know cyclists
cycling very happily considerable
distances in their eighties I have no
fears of not being able to do that the
point I'm trying to make is that we need
pure car movements that also implies
although it's not necessarily the case
because this is an examination but it
implies that we should be considering
the whole thing in toto as has been
mentioned public transport the use of
buses carpooling we've got to be a
little bit more creative we started off
talking about environmental health
impacts the recent study has shown the
depression is related directly to
vehicle pollution in specific areas
peaks of certain times of day in
critical areas in seven or eight British
Azshara English cities have been shown
to be directly related to serious health
problems and into the tune of actual
depression we have oh and intelligence
actually people's intelligence actually
drops in the presence of traffic fumes
and make no mistake about it it is
traffic fumes and as a cyclist I can
assure you I get more of them than most
much much nicer for people in their
little metal boxes but do think about
that aspect as well I don't want to go
around with the face masks and stuff
like that so I support the amendment but
I also think we should just get on with
it and when it comes back to review by
the way let's examine all the
possibilities not just what's in the
motion Thank You Council McClure cut so
Dawson yes I said may have my support to
this motion but I wonder actually
whether should point out with this that
we act whilst we're reviewing on parking
Commission
it's most unfortunate that Bieber have
chosen with the planning application in
Hadley to remove what will be hundred
spaces which are currently not actually
use and this is something that obviously
I was firmly against because it's only
going to make four hundred and fifty
thousand and we do need the parking
provision in Hadley so I hope that that
can be considered in this review and
secondly as I said before I think the
residential parking permits is an
absolute must because we have a
situation in Hadley where it's
completely now all the private raids off
the main high street all everybody
coming in to work now because they can't
park where they used to at the end in
the high street are all parking in the
high street so shoppers can't get in so
I would very much like to see when we
look at the the level of capacity here
actually what we're actually going to do
about it are we going to make extra car
parks are we going to do the residents
parking permits and you know actually
get on with it because we've been
discussing it for three or four years
now that side of it Thank You councillor
Dawson
cuts in Newman did you want to speak he
had reserved the right to speak up yes
please just a few words just dis
remember this is a review so I asked all
our fellow counselors to support this
and as Arthur would say make it our
mission to sort out party Thanks Thank
You Kelso Newman um cancer Lindsay I
wasn't sure whether I was allowed to
speak or proposed the amendments you can
you can now sum up your I'm sorry okay
yeah thank you
yeah just to pick up on a few points I
completely agree with my colleague here
about we shouldn't wash your hands of
responsibility for buses just because at
the moment the county council happened
to subsidize them and they're now
talking about withdrawing the subsidy
from a lot of them it's which runs its
own bus company and it finances it from
parking fees in Ipswich there's no
reason why we can't look at that kind of
thing as a solution there's no reason
why we as a as an authority can't take
responsibility for providing public
transport to people in towns like
Cyprian Hadley where people are actually
driving when they don't need to and this
is a if you look at it that way if we
look at it as sustainable transport
rather than just parking it's a
win-win-win for everybody because I see
it as three groups of people there's
people who don't actually have access to
a car or a van and in Sudbury alone
suffering corn arbors 2,250 families who
do not have access to a car so those are
the people we should be rewarding for
not truck clogging up our roads with
cars not sucking up taking up space with
parking not polluting then there are
then there are a group of people who
maybe have to drive except that will
never get to zero cars there are people
who live
remote places of have to drive but but
then they're a big big section in the
middle that can actually flex their
behavior but can if they just thought
about it for a minute they could cycle
to pinwheel five miles if you use
electric bike that increases your range
so I highly recommend it
you could cycle the pin mill in five
miles without breaking into a sweat so
we so there's a win for those people and
and in getting more exercise getting out
and about not having to find a parking
space and there's a win for the people
who insist on using the car will have to
use their car because when they get to
Sudbury or Hadley there are more spaces
for them they're not having to fight for
the spaces because all those other
people have switched to moving by foot
or bus or cycle and the fourth wheel
which nobody is mentioned is we just
passed the climate emergency a couple of
months ago
we're supposed to be reducing our carbon
emissions to zero by 2030 it's an
emergency and we talk why are we talking
about increasing parking it just doesn't
make sense so thank you please support
this motion Thank You Council in c-cups
Libya do you have anything to add well
just a couple of points that somebody
just whispered to me that we used to
have laid in petrol which I'm well aware
of and that we took that out and put in
alcohol and perhaps they were referring
to some of the comments when you were
saying about some of the difficulties
going on but anyway thatís all you'd
parking fees I didn't mention that but
canceled in Zlin you did this motion
isn't going to ask for any increase in
parking charges or deep increases it's
just looking at all the other options
that is something that I firmly believe
that the partn program we've got in
subgrade hadley we should stick to at
the
wherever that will be looked at at a
later date it's nothing to do with this
motion I think coming back to the real
world
yes what you ain't blowing might be what
we all envision should happen but at the
end of the day people will get in their
cars if we head the new house in the
States or new developments yes they will
get in their cars there is no way that
we can stop that as much as even I would
agree with you we would like to it can't
be done so we do need to try and make
sure that we can accommodate some of
this part and and control it better and
yes if we can give encourage people to
get on their bikes to use public
transport and I won't get into that
argument because that's kind of chemical
and then that is the right course of
action but to not pursue this and not to
certainly a real figure madam chairman
we need to make sure that we action this
and we deliver something from it because
at the end of the day the public out
there do expect us to and you're part of
2,000 people in Sudbury and cornered
without access to a car the population
of Sudbury and great Coronado is 20,000
and that that is a lot of people and
that's without the ones that come in
from outside the area so we really don't
need any lectures about the population
of submarine great corner thank you
thank you can't severe classification
no thank you Thank You Kelsey I thank
you all counselors for your interesting
comment so the motion as amended with
your comments tonight would be referred
to the cabinet for decision thank you
we're now coming to the end of our
meeting thank you all for attending
please note the date of the next meeting
is Tuesday 10th December 2019 at 5:30
the meeting closes at 701 councillors
welcome to the extraordinary council
meeting as members already aware the
only substantive item on the agenda has
been withdrawn
therefore I declare the meeting closed
thank you